il est 15 heures passées de quelques
minutes un bateau situé au bout de ce
ponton vient d'exploser
ce plaisancier était amarré juste à côté
il est sous le choc je n'en remets pas
par un petit café l'explosion j'ai pensé
à un avion qui avait passé le mur du son
mais en montant l'escalier depuis son
mon bateau je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais plus de portes que j'avais trois
vitres qui avait cassé et surtout
surtout que l'arrière du bateau qui
était à côté de moi était posé sur le
mien l'explosion est intervenue sur un
bateau de plaisance le propriétaire
grièvement brûlé a été transporté au chu
de dijon
selon les premiers témoignages l'origine
accidentelle du sinistre
fait peu de doute d'après ce que j'ai
entendu il faisait des travaux à bord
oui savait pas de quelle nature
je crois qui perçait des réservoirs
c'est ce que j'ai cru entendre qui
perçait des réservoirs d'essence sur son
bateau ce donc ce qui est risqué et
dangereux
après avoir dégagé les bateaux les plus
touchés par l'explosion les pompiers ont
installé en fin d'après-midi un barrage
flottant pour limiter les pollutions
[Musique]
on